over the past several years spacex has
received a lot of well-deserved praise
and acclimation for the strides in
lowering rocket launch cost
another organization however that isn't
nearly as celebrated
is india space organization isro for
decades
isro has slowly but consistently been
driving down the cost of missions across
the board
including orbital missions lunar
missions and even martian missions
so here's a story of the space underdog
isro
isro was officially founded on august 15
but the organization's roots stretched
back decades the earliest known roots
traced back to indian physicist
sk mithra in the 1920s mithra was most
famously known for his experiments
relating to ionosphere soundings
and ionosphere sounding is a
telecommunications technique used to
identify the most optimal radio
frequency
in a given area scientists use this
information to form a better
understanding of the upper atmosphere
and earth's near space environment aside
from sk mitzra we also had cv ramen and
magnet zaha who also completed a variety
of space-related experiments throughout
the 1920s
and 1930s but the first major leap
forward wouldn't come to the 1940s
when the physical research laboratory
and the tata institute of fundamental
research were founded
these two organizations were founded by
scientists vikram sarabhai
and homie baba respectively each
organization
leveraged nearby universities and
research laboratories to conduct
experiments relating to cosmic radiation
upper atmospheric studies and high
altitude tests
in 1962 vikram sarabhai would convince
prime minister nehru
to set up the indian national committee
for space research
and soon after india would begin
experimenting with sounding rockets
which eventually led to the formation of
isro or the indian space research
organization in 1969
since then isro has developed five
different launch vehicles
with the first being the satellite
launch vehicle or slv
the sov was a rather small rocket with a
payload capacity of only 40 kilograms
despite its relative simplicity it took
isro seven
years to develop and unfortunately the
first launch in 1979
would end up filling nonetheless a
faulty valve would end up causing a
rocket to crash into the bay of bengal
just 317 seconds after launch isro would
give the sov another try just a year
later in 1980
and this time the launch would be
successful isro would successfully
launch the rorkeny rs-1 satellite into
orbit
which made india the sixth country to
reach orbit slv would go on to be used
two more times with mixed results
the third launch itself was successful
but the satellite was launched in too
low of an orbit
which caused the satellite to deorbit
nine days after launch
the fourth launch would take place in
1983 and this mission would be a success
allowing isro to send an earth
observation satellite into orbit
following the success of the slv isro
would attempt to make a more advanced
version of the slv
called the aslv the asov
was a five-stage solid fuel rocket that
aimed to deliver payloads into
geostationary orbit
unfortunately this rocket would end up
being a massive disappointment
throughout its lifetime the aslv would
complete four launches
out of which three were failures the
first failure took place in 1987
when the first stage of the rocket
failed to ignite after launch
just one year later isro would try again
but this time the launcher would end up
disintegrating the third launch of the
aslv would take place in 1992. and
similar to the slv failure the satellite
would be released in too low of an orbit
and they would end up deorbiting the
fourth and final launch of the aslv
would take place in 1994
and this launch was actually a success
but
given the checkered past of the asl v
isro would decide to discontinue their
rocket and focus their effort on the
pslv
or the polar satellite launch vehicle
the pslv was designed to deliver
payloads into sun synchronous orbit
and this rocket is what would really
prove the capability of isro
ironically the first flight of the pslv
in 1994
would end up being a failure however
pslv would end up having a streak of 50
successful launches
the pslv is actually still used to this
day
and it has even put 342 foreign
satellites from 36 different countries
into various orbits up until this year
the pslv
actually held a record for deploying the
most number of satellites into sun
synchronous orbit
in a single launch aside from being an
extremely reliable launch vehicle
the pslv is also extremely cost
efficient each launch is estimated to
cost between 18
and 28 million dollars well estimate on
the higher side and call it 25 million
for launch the pslv is capable of
delivering 3
800 kilograms into low earth orbit
meaning that it costs 6579 dollars per
kilogram
to put that into perspective nasa's
upcoming sls rocket is expected to be
able to put 70 metric tons into orbit
but the price tag per launch is over two
billion dollars
this means that the cost per kilogram is
28 572 dollars
which is over four times the cost of
pslv now
pslv isn't nearly as cost efficient as
the falcon 9
which only costs 2 193 dollars per
kilogram
which is only about a third of the cost
of pslv
nonetheless the pslv is way more
efficient than options coming out from
nasa today
and the pslv was designed way back in
the 1980s and 90s
anyway isro's next rocket was the
geosynchronous satellite launch vehicle
or the gslv this is basically an updated
version of the aslv
and has a payload capacity of 5 000
kilograms the gslv has thus far had 13
launches
out of which eight were successful two
are partial failures and three were
complete failures
the gslv is still used today to send
larger payloads into geostationary
transfer orbit
and that brings us into isro's final
rocket which is the gslv mark
iii this rocket was developed in the
early 2000s
and is isro's most powerful rocket
capable of sending 10
000 kilograms into low earth orbit
similar to the pslv
the gslv mark iii is quite cost
efficient in terms of cost per kilogram
the gslv mark iii cost 51 million
dollars per launch
meaning that it costs 5 100 per kilogram
so far
the gslv mark iii has only had four
launches and all of them have been a
success
it definitely looks like isro has
significantly improved their reliability
compared to their early days
anyway moving on to notable israel
projects completed with these rockets
we first have a handful of satellite
programs the irs series for instance
consists of a group of satellites in sun
synchronous orbit
these satellites allow india to map and
monitor natural resources such as fresh
water
another group of satellites managed by
isro is the insat series
this group is located in geostationary
transfer orbit and it provides
telecommunications and broadcasting
capabilities
fun fact insat is the largest domestic
communication system in the asia pacific
region
isro also has satellites within their
guggen satellite navigation system
and within ir nss these groups provide
navigation
communications surveillance and many
more services to isro
and india isro satellites are cool
but where it gets really interesting is
their lunar and martian missions
after china successfully sent humans
into space in the early 2000s
india started to focus on trying to send
humans to the moon
and the first step in this journey was
sending a probe to the moon
in 2008 isro used a modified version of
the pslv to launch chandran 1 to the
moon
this probe became the first probe to
prove the existence of water
on the moon according to chandrayaan 1
the lunar pulse hold over 600 billion
kilograms of ice
isro wouldn't attempt another lunar
mission for quite some time
but the next attempt would be a massive
step up compared to chandrayaan 1.
chandrayaan-2 was launched in 2019 using
the gslv
mark iii and it consisted of a lunar
orbiter
lander and rover the goal of the mission
was to prove isro's ability to complete
a soft landing on the lunar surface
unfortunately though a software glitch
would result in the lander deviating
from the planned path
and crashing into the surface of the
moon isro
is planning on trying the soft landing
once again with chandrayaan-3
which is expected to take place in 2022
moving on to their martian mission
we have yan 1. in november of 2013
israel launched mongolian 1 to mars and
the spacecraft would successfully enter
martian orbit in september of 2014.
this made india the first country to
enter martian orbit on their first
attempt
what's even more impressive though is
that they were able to complete the
entire mission
at a record low cost of 74 million
dollars
to put that in perspective martian
orbital missions completed by nasa
generally cost hundreds of millions of
dollars for instance
the mars odyssey mission cost 297
million dollars
the maven mission cost 671 million
dollars and the mars reconnaissance
orbiter
cost 720 million dollars mongolian one
was literally almost one tenth of the
cost of the mars reconnaissance orbiter
clearly isro has made massive strides
when it comes to reducing the cost of
space missions
but they're just getting started looking
forward israel plans to launch audit the
l1 to the sun in 2022
chokriyan won to venus in 2023 and
mongolian ii to mars in 2024
they also have a mission to jupiter
planned but we don't have the details of
that mission yet
looking forward though the future of
isro is looking especially bright
as her budget continues to be increased
year after year
isro's budget has tripled over just the
last 10 years
this is in stark contrast to nasa whose
budget peaked 50 years ago
at the end of the day isro is one of the
most advanced space organizations
in the world they are not quite on the
level of spacex when it comes to cost
efficiency
but there are magnitudes ahead of other
government-funded space programs
considering this it's just a matter of
time until isro places humans in orbit
and eventually on the moon and mars did
you guys realize how cost efficient isro
is
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys hope that nasa will soon
focus on reducing cost
themselves and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one